sometimes you don't think they choose
the right man
what what what is it for you what is it
that that i mean
yeah so she was so so you guys said like
women don't always like they might pick
future over the other guy yeah
pearl said you know do you think that
the women in your life choose the best
men
and you said no
what for you then then
quantifies or qualifies the best man if
they're picking who is it that they're
picking versus what uh versus who you
think they should pick what what what
are the distinguishing characteristics
in your own words
i would say a guy who's going to pro
who's going to provide security for her
emotionally physically and financially
and i bet the guy who can best do that
all three
in my opinion is the best is the better
choice
because thing is the futures of the
world they're not providing that
emotional security for you
probably not they might provide the
physical one if you're if if you're
there but how often is he going to be
with you like once every two weeks every
day
every two weeks
um so that's what i would say the one
the one who can do all those three in a
good good standard to be honest
oh um
yeah mainly what he said that they just
prioritized like um the girls feelings
emotional security what not
not too much on the uh financial
stability-wise but obviously it'll be
nice if they're financially stable but
like the other two would be more of a
priority
pretty much the same what they said just
don't feel had this
he's he's trustworthy like
the things that needs to get done he
gets it done
and
i feel like we've again
you know you just know you know and
we've
and so would you say the same for
women then are these also not things you
would want in terms of someone who's em
financially stable and and
is emotionally
uh intelligent and can be there for you
emotionally and and offer that stability
and who is also trustworthy would you
say that's a universal thing do you
think that's that's the same for women
too not exactly well i don't emotional
security yes
i don't think guys look to women for
physical security to be honest yeah i
don't think guys look to women for
financial security i don't think most
guys do are you saying that
men
don't care that i can deadlift a lot oh
no they'll care if you can
because if you're taller than most guys
they're definitely looking for you to be
physically secure for them yeah i want
that no
i've seen your bench press is quite
heavy as well
thank you
i will i will jump in here and say so i
was a team gb power lifter
and so i will say yes like and
yeah man but like it's interesting to
see how men react to that like to do
with the strength thing i think for a
lot of guys they're like yo i feel like
i've seen you somewhere
really yeah because team g power that
makes sense right
but um
i i think for uh it's interesting to see
how guys react to that this is
definitely a side tangent but like it is
really interesting to see how guys react
to that because it's like oh yo you're
like you're strong and [ __ ] you can look
after yourself before that i did emma um
not mma i don't think guys really care
do you think they can i don't i don't i
don't think i don't think i think they
think it's cool i think they go oh
that's you
is it cool to you that i can bench a lot
is it like is it i find it different but
background and it's but um i've seen
like a lot of my friends back in like
college and whatnot they were quite
skinny and they didn't used to hit jim
and they talked about how or if a girl
had a bit of striations or their bit of
muscle automatically they're just
cancelled they just look at him uh yeah
and stuff like that yeah oh wow
no i've heard that too that's like so it
depends on the sort of guy really
yeah
i think it's sexual security i think i
think that's something maybe these guys
just
i just think guys like girls in shape
right
yeah a girl who looks after herself yeah
yeah and she doesn't well
she doesn't have to have like a six-pack
or anything like that like but
just a girl who looks after herself
especially if he looks after himself
do you know what i mean
[Music]
what is the biggest red flags you guys
see in girls
she doesn't offer to pay her share in
the first date i disagree with you on
that
i don't think that's that big of a deal
she doesn't offer to pay on a first date
no because she's not entitled to my time
all my money yeah but sometimes guys
just offer to pay i'm not gonna fight
it's good that a guy pays but i'm saying
it's
the lack of gesture is a red flag the
lack of gesture yeah because it goes off
sometimes i just feel really awkward i'm
gonna be honest sometimes i'm like my
guy so let's say you see a girl yeah
yeah and you turn and you asked her to
come on a date with you yep
you took her out of her own space i
didn't take her anywhere she chose to
come i hear that thank you she was
chilling like she wasn't
thank you she's not gonna she's not
gonna say yes if she doesn't wanna come
yeah she wanted to come but she wasn't
gonna ask him so he asked her all right
what i'm saying is
is you're you see a girl that you like
yep and you asked her that can't take
you on a date
you then feel like you she should then
also pay no no i didn't say she should
pay i said she should she should offer
no no she should offer to pay her share
if i when i if i take girl if i ask a
girl out on a date
i'm always going to pay
but i want her to offer to pay her [ __ ]
that's what i was getting that i was
just making sure that
that was the main thing that you always
want to pay because you took it out yeah
but you just want to see like
if she would help out too
it's a la it's for me it's just showing
it's it's a sign of appreciation she's
like
you don't have to do this for me
but i appreciate when you do
because she the things that she would do
that she doesn't have to do for me but
i'll appreciate like
if she
i know if she cooks for me it's like
it's not i'm not like oh because you're
a woman you have to do that so i'm like
oh thanks baby i was super thankful and
i was like oh that's so nice like thank
you so much you would still think i was
like entitled
uh
because most guys just grab it no if you
that's what i'm saying yeah saying thank
you okay by being being appreciative
okay i'm not gonna fight you for it i
won't no but i'd be like oh no i don't
mind if you spit this all right no it's
okay
okay great thanks but i do
i'm not gonna go quick then we're like
let me okay great
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie to you i
do mind if you asked me no but it's just
it's just about it's just about it's
just about being polite it's just about
being polite that's how i say thank you
that's still polite yeah that's all
right that's all right
okay glad to know i wouldn't get i
wouldn't get sent packing
i don't say thank you but like if she
doesn't even say she doesn't offend she
doesn't even say thank you i i know the
vibe by the way i'm taking you out again
i know i know the vibe you're talking
about i get it i know i'd say
i i think if i think though if you if
you start to say that you think that um
women should pay half which by the way i
always think which is not what i'm
saying
no no but i'm saying if you expect a
woman to at least offer even if you say
no
um i think then does that not imply that
you also talking back to the
expectations of what you want from a
woman does that then not just say you
don't just want a woman who's pretty and
in shape you know i want a woman who is
financially stable because no it's poor
woman i think yeah and polite but no but
if a woman wasn't financially stable she
would not offer because if you said yeah
all right and then she's like sure i've
got no money in my bank account but i
think it's the polite would you agree
with like it's because you want her to
be polite
yeah i think i think if i'm being honest
i think part of it